der Gasleck Krimi in der Ostsee er lässt
immer noch eine Vielzahl von Fragen
offen eine sabotage-attacke ein Angriff
auf unser Gas wie gut sind wir vor Putin
geschützt die Bundesregierung reagiert
auf die zerstörte Gaspipeline in der
Ostsee Innenministerin nennt sie Feser
sprach gegenüber Bild von einer
Zeitenwende bei der inneren Sicherheit
ein Funken Hoffnung in dieser Zeit das
nato-schutzschild in der Ostsee auf der
Insel Bornholm
versteckt unter zwei hangar-zelten
stehen auf dem zivilen Flughafen von
Bornholm 2 F16 Kampfjets nicht ohne
Grund Bild Reporter Sebastian Prengel
weiß mit diesen Kampfflugzeugen
verteidigt und kontrolliert die dänische
Luftwaffe die nato-außengrenzen die 15
Millionen Euro Jagdflugzeuge sind das
nato-schutzschild in der Ostsee diese
Flugzeuge Wind mit modernsten
Waffensystemen ausgestattet die sind
jederzeit einsatzbereit und die stehen
hier seit dem Beginn des Krieges in der
Ukraine seit dem Angriff auf die
Gaspipeline ins Nord Stream 1 und 2
brodelt es im Baltischen Meer Gas steigt
aus vier Lecks an die Oberfläche
Dänemarks Verteidigungsminister Morten
Bosco schätzt die Gefahr ein
die baltische See ist und wird auch in
Zukunft eine Region mit hohen Spannungen
sein wir beobachten wie die Russen immer
wieder unsere Grenzen testen testing auf
dem Wasser und oben in der Luft und
deshalb sind die Jets hier stationiert
um genau darauf schneller reagieren zu
können
und sie werden auch hier bleiben
[Musik]
den russischen Mix sind die wendigen F16
Jäger weit überlegen das sorgt für
Sicherheit der Verteidigungsminister es
gibt einen erzunehmenden Vorfall vor
unserer Küste und die Situation ist
wirklich ernst es hat heftige
Explosionen gegeben das kann jeder an
der sprudelndem Wasseroberfläche
erkennen die F16 Kampfjets sind die
ersten die das sprudelnde Gas am
Montagnachmittag entdecken
nach Bildinformationen soll einer der
Kampfpiloten nach dem Einsatz gesagt
haben die Bilder sein wie aus einem
Actionfilm
bis Sonntag soll das restliche Gas in
den Röhren entwickeln sein dann wird man
die Pipeline in 70 Metern Tiefe genauer
untersuchen und die Ursache für die lex
finden fest steht aber schon jetzt
es ist eindeutig dass das hier kein
Zufall ist dieser Angriff hat
professionell geplant und vorbereitet
[Musik]
der Krieg rückt immer näher